[موسيقى]
أنت على بعد دقائق من الإقلاع
وكان هذا الطفل الذي توقف عن التنفس ،
تذكر لحظة ما كان
سبب الضيق
وكيف أبدأ العمل معًا كفريق واحد
لحسن الحظ ، كان الطفل ديفيد
قد نجح في ذلك  خلع اسمي
أنسون ، أنا من طاقم الطائرة في الخطوط الجوية السنغافورية
، أنا أيضًا طبيبة متطوعة ،
هذه القصة الكبيرة من
الخطوط الجوية السنغافورية
[موسيقى]
أستمتع دائمًا بالتحدي وأكون
دائمًا في حالة تنقل.
لتجربة
المزيد والطيران أعطاني الفرصة
لكنني لا أطير ، لقد تطوعت مع
الوحدة المعيارية للدفاع المدني السنغافوري
كمسعف متطوع ولدي عيش
هذه الحياة المزدوجة لمدة سبع سنوات تقريبًا
الآن كل سفينة من سفينتنا لا يمكن التنبؤ بها
لأن حالات الطوارئ لدينا  مختلف
كطبيب متطوع أتابع
سيارتي الإسعاف Twista و EDF
وسيبدأ اليوم عندما تأتي مكالمات الطوارئ
[موسيقى]
منذ سنوات ، أردت أن أصبح ممرضة
لأنني أردت  لمساعدة الناس على
إحداث فرق في حياتهم ، حيث منحني جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
بالفعل هذه الفرصة
للمساهمة في المجتمع
بمهاراتي طوعيًا يسمح لي بالبقاء على
اتصال بالعالم الطبي
كطبيب
كل ثانية كل دقيقة مهمة لأن
هذه هي الحياة و  الموت
[موسيقى]
نظرًا لأن طاقم المقصورة أبطأ
وأكثر رشاقة وأناقة بسبب
خلفيتي الطبية ، يمكنني التقاط التفاصيل
بشكل أفضل وجعلني أكثر وعياً بأن
الأشياء البسيطة التي نفتقدها للناس
تشعر بالرضا ، فهذه أشياء
مهمة تحتاج إلى  لاحظنا أننا
فهمنا وحضرنا ، وقد تأثر هذا أيضًا
بالنهج المتبع في أن أكون مسعفًا ،
كما أن هذه المسؤوليات
مهمة بالنسبة لي وتعطي معنى لحياتي
[موسيقى]
50000 دولار على متن إيرين ، مرحبًا بك على متن
شركة طيران سنغافورة ، بنادق الأرز الناي إلين.
ليس سنغافورة
، من الجيد معرفة أنني أساعد
الناس من خلال عملي عندما
أرى الابتسامات والنظرة على وجوههم
مجزية حقًا ومرضية
والبعض منا  أصبحوا أصدقاء في بعض الأحيان
، يتعلق الأمر فقط بإخبار
الناس أنهم في صحة جيدة وآمنة
يمكن أن تكون أكبر من عيش
حياتين يسمحان لي بفعل ذلك فقط
[الموسيقى]